blade run at twenty forty niners are
stunning neo-noir sci-fi movie in which
LAPD officer K and covers a rap look at
mystery that threatens to overturn
society yippie Kay may be lovers it's
Jan here and today I'm delving into the
thrilling Blade Runner sequel to explain
the ending the major plot twist some
unanswered questions and what they mean
for a potential Blade Runner three movie
I'm also starting my 2049 giveaway from
one of these Blade Runner Funko pops for
a chance to win make sure you're
subscribed to flicks in the city and let
me know your thoughts or theories about
the movie in the comments below
quick warning I'll be diving deep into
the world of Blade Runner 2049 and
discussing spoilers so take care if
you've not seen the movie yet the
mystery at the heart of the Blade Runner
sequel is that Rachel the replicants who
fled with Deckard at the end of the
original movie gave birth to a child
something not previously thought to be
possible Rachel died during childbirth
and her baby was delivered via an
emergency c-section performed by Sacre
Morton the replicant who Ryan Gosling's
K is hunting at the beginning of the
film staffer buried Rachel's remains
beneath the tree outside his farmhouse
and just before he's killed by K the old
model replicant alludes to what happened
when he accuses new replicants like Kay
of not knowing anything because they've
never seen a miracle back at the LAPD
after the bones have been analyzed
revealing that a replicant gave birth
Kay's boss let Tennant Joshi played by
Robin Wright explains that public
knowledge of this secret would shatter
the current status quo because the idea
that a replicant can give birth means
they're no longer dependent on their
human creators or masters for their
existence and that they're more human
than humans or as K says to Joshi to be
born is to have a soul
Joshi considers the revelation to be far
too dangerous and orders Kay to destroy
all evidence first as he continues his
investigation kay finds himself on a
path that appears to be leading him to
the conclusion that he is the missing
child that Rachel gave birth to the
major plot twist comes when the injured
Kay wakes up among a group of rebel
replicants who informed him that he
isn't Rachael's true born child the
rebel leader Fraser tells Kay that the
true child is actually a girl not a boy
this moment links back to the scene
earlier in the movie when Kay and joy
were examining the DNA of the missing
child Kay discovered records for two
children with matching
DNA one was male and one was female
though the females records said she died
from a genetic disorder however Dec hard
had taught the rebels had to scramble
the records and cover their tracks to
protect the identity of the true child
and that child is actually dr. Anna
Stalin the memory designer who cave is
a-- today leah in the movie so why did k
have Aniston's memory and believe it was
really his own well when he asked anna
to examine his memory she cried and
seemed to confirm it was a real memory
and not a manufactured one and when k
visited the orphanage he found the
carved wooden horse from his memory
which also implies that the events from
his memory did take place joy also
encouraged this belief that he was the
miracle child when she told him that she
thought he was special and put the idea
in his head that he should have a real
name not just a serial number as he's
important and I talk in more detail
about the significance of Kay's names in
my video on hidden meanings in the film
so the reason all of this made sense
decay despite the fact it wasn't true
was because his memory had been designed
by anna stalin and she had either
deliberately or unconsciously added some
of her own real-life memories into her
designs
after all anna did tell Kay that every
artist includes a little bit of
themselves in their creations
mariette also seemed to recognize the
wooden horse in Kay's apartment
suggesting that various replicants had
ended up with this particular memory and
also noticed that the filmmakers chose
to portray the child in Kay's dream with
short straggly hair so that initially he
assumes it's a boy but obviously it
could also be a girl by the way the
presence of the toy horse in 2049 is a
neat callback to the unicorn in Ridley
Scott's Blade Runner and therefore a
link to Harrison Ford's Deckard after
this discovery K tracks down Deckard
who's being taken away by love k has to
fight love who he eventually kills but
not before getting badly injured himself
still wounded K takes Deckard to meet
his daughter Anna at her Institute but
once there he stays outside lying down
on the steps to the building this seems
like it's the end of the line for K as
his character arc is complete he's lost
everything
yes he's also solved the truth his own
identity and also fulfilled his role to
bring Deckard and Anna together and on
top of that the music which plays during
this C
is the same as a music that plays in the
original Bladerunner movie over batties
tears and the rain monologue it's a sad
but beautiful moment yet while Batty's
fate at the end of Blade Runner is
crystal clear 20:49 leaves a slither of
ambiguity in the fate of its protagonist
so if the filmmakers did want to bring
Kay back for a future sequel and if Ryan
Gosling also wished to return it could
still be possible as for Anna and
Deckard they're reunited at the end but
their story finishes on something of a
cliffhanger as we're left with questions
such as if and when she'll be told she's
the key to the simmering replicant
revolution and also whether she's a
replicant a human or a hybrid of sorts
and that possible replicant rebellion is
another huge potential storyline that
could be explored in a sequel there's
plenty of prejudice against replicants
from humans in Blade Runner 2049 for
example Kay has to put up with slurs and
insults directed at him in both his
housing block and at work in the LAPD
Fraser wants to free her people and
tells Kay that our lives mean nothing
next to the storm that's coming dying
for the right cause is the most human
thing we can do and although Fraser told
Kay the only way to protect the miracle
child was to kill Deckard he chooses not
to do that in fact just as Baz he saves
Deckard in the 1982 film kay does the
same in this one asserting his
independence and humanity wants more
just as he did when he lied to that
tenant Joshi about the fate of the
replicant baby still Fraser is
determined to reveal Rachel's baby to
the world when the time is right and
says the child will lead their army a
thread which could be continued in a
future movie although to be honest I'd
be happy if the story ended here rather
than trying to tie everything up too
neatly in future films earlier I
mentioned joy Kay's holographic
companion and she's a very interesting
part of the story even if what her
character says can often be a bit of a
red herring in terms of the final
resolution of the film joy is as the
adverts for her point out everything you
want to see and everything you want to
hear so when we first meet her she
switches through a number of different
outfits and looks until Casey is one he
likes and when she tells Kay that he's
special and important she's probably
just telling him
he wants to hear although I suspect that
Joey was set up as a very intelligent AI
who can figure out what our owner wants
and fulfill those needs there were some
hints in the movie that she might be
able to develop her own feelings and
possibly identity there are some clear
parallels between joy and Scarlett
Johansson's AI character Samantha from
Spike Jones's movie her for instance of
sex scenes in both movies although the
extent of Joy's real autonomy is left
more ambiguous in Blade Runner 2049 for
example when joy said I love you to Kay
just before love crushed and effectively
killed her was that real genuine emotion
or just what she was programmed to do in
other words she said what Kay wanted to
hear at that moment either way I thought
the performance of actress Anna the
Animus was cleverly ambiguous so that
were left wondering whether joy managed
to become truly sentient before she was
destroyed Neander Wallace who has
something of a god complex and calls his
replicant creations angels is also on
the hunt for the missing replicant child
he wants to create millions of new
replicants as he believes they are the
key to rebuilding the Earth's
environment and eventually colonizing
the stars
Wallace's view of history is that
civilizations only advanced when they
were willing to harness the power of a
slave population and he sees replicant
reproduction as a solution to creating
new replicants on mass Wallace has
always been willing to push the limits
of technology in pursuit of his own
agenda for instance he was the one who
got replicant prohibition repealed when
he developed a new model which he
demonstrated would always obey and never
rebel it's curious that Wallace has a
chip or socket in his neck and little
camera drones that float around in his
vicinity which presumably are there to
help him see or sense things his visual
impairments could be a metaphor for his
world view as although he understands
the power of replicants
he's blinkered and only wants to use
them for one purpose as slaves but even
his most trusted replicants like love
appear to have possible design defects
for example love seems to respond
emotionally in particularly stressful
situations such as crying just before
wallace slices open the belly of his
newborn female replicant or when love
realizes she has to kill Joshy
unlike love though Wallace clearly
appears to have survived the movie so
has the potential to reappear in a
future story or sequel by the way
Rachael's pregnancy
some new details about her special
prototype design that Terrell mentioned
in the first movie it seems that she had
more real human parts and other standard
replicants at a time for example
reproductive organs that opens up the
possibility that to become pregnant she
mated with a human which would imply
Deckard is human however Rachael's
pregnancy might not conform to normal
human biology
meaning that Deckard could still be a
replicant and have impregnated her and
given the religious symbolism in many of
Ridley Scott's films it could even be
that this miracle replicant birth is
akin to biblical tales for miraculous
virgin birth or of infertile women who
gave birth to children who went on to
become important figures for example
Genesis tells of jacob's wife Rachel who
couldn't have children until God enabled
her to conceive and intriguingly like
blade runners Rachel the biblical Rachel
also died during childbirth as the
Deckard the question of whether he's a
replicant or not is acknowledged in the
sequel but the answer remains ambiguous
some think the movies directed an evil
nerve has said he deliberately wanted to
do as he thinks that questions can be
more interesting than their answers the
under Wallis also touches on the Deckard
replicant theory in the scene where he
holds Deckard hostage and strongly
suggests that Tyrell deliberately
engineered the meeting between dekada
Rachel so that he would fall in love
with her Wallis actually took over the
assets of the Tyrell corporation after
it went bankrupt so it's possible that
he discovered something about this inter
Al's records and Wallis further fuels
the debate over whether Deckard is
replicant or human when he ponders
whether it was love or mathematical
precision that brought the two together
so what did you think of Blade Runner
2049 and if you've seen the original how
do you think the two movies compare and
are there any moments that still
confused you I'd love to hear what you
think in the comments below and also
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
for your chance to win a Blade Runner
2049 Funko pop I'll be announcing the
winner on an upcoming video so be sure
to hit the bell to get notified of all
my new videos and if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up and you
can also tap the screen for more Blade
Runner and other videos you might like
thanks for watching and see you next
time you became movie lovers